cho chương hoàn trong lúc mở đầu năm 2018, được viên in đách lên mức cao kỷ lục một nền trinh trăm mây tâm điểm.
Tuy nhiên sau đó, chỉ số điều trình sâu có thể điểm luy về quen một nền với trăm 4 mi điểm,
trước khi hồi phục nhẹ ngay trước khi nghỉ tét, kết viên ngày 18, 2 ước mức một nền tâm trăm 20 mi bún điểm.
Cao hơn khoảng 4 mi điểm sau với cuối năm 2018.
Dễn bên tị trường cho thấy sự phân hoa sọn hết, nhỏng của phíu vũ nhận nước tăng mạnh đầu năm,
nhiều kỷ vọng trình sách trong khi nhỏng hộ viên và một số mạng tăng nống năm 2019,
chữa áp lực trước lời, nhà đầu tương nước ngoài cũng suy chi bán sòng hàng nhìn bị đồng,
sau cơ cấu xanh mục và biến đậu tỷ giá.
Theo nhận định của Trinh ra, nhiều yếu tổ dù gió ngãn hạn đã phần hãnh vào giá của phíu,
lại sớt và thành khoảng có giấu hiệu hạn yên, tạo đô kiện để giọng tiền quay trở lại.
Sau khi nghỉ tét, tị trường được khi vọng với vào nghiệp hồi phục mới, hướng tới vùng một nền trinh trăm điểm,
và có thể thích lập đến cao hơn trong năm 2018.